Speaker 3: People are flushing
toilets 10 times 15 times,
Speaker 1: and we were wondering what on
earth is going on with Trump and toilets
that he's so obsessed with needing to flush
10 to 15 times. We have now figured it out,
and it is unbelievable. New York Times reporter
Maggie Haberman writes in her forthcoming book
that Trump's White House toilet. Would
be clogged. With documents that Donald
Trump was flushing down the toilet. This is is
this the explanation? Is this the explanation?
Axios reports while President Trump was in office
staff at the White House residence, Trump was
doing this with his personal toilet periodically
would discover wads of printed paper clogging a
toilet and believed that the president had flushed
pieces of paper. Maggie Haberman scoops in her
forthcoming book Confidence Men. This adds, I love
this language. This adds a vivid new dimension
to Trump's lapses in preserving government
documents. Haberman reports Trump has told
people that since leaving office, he has remained
in contact with Kim Jong UN, whose love letters,
as Trump once called them, were among documents
the National Archives retrieved from Mar a Lago.
The news of White House toilet flushing comes
as the National Archives has asked the Biden
Justice Department to examine Trump's handling of
White House records. So let's go back. Remember
this bizarre viral rant from Trump about
elements of bathrooms and 10 to 15 flushes?
Speaker 3: We have a situation where we're
looking very strongly at sinks and showers
and other elements of bathrooms where you can turn
the faucet on in areas where there's tremendous
amounts of water, where the water rushes
out to sea because you could never handle it
and you don't get any water, you turn
on the faucet, you don't get any water,
they take a shower and water comes dripping
out, dripping out, very quietly dripping out.
People are flushing toilets 10 times 15 times.
Speaker 1: It's so insane because people have
been sanctioned for far less document
destruction than what Trump did. So like,
there is a very real story here, guys, which
is Trump ran on Hillary can't be trusted with,
with documents, with information she can't private
email all this different stuff. And meanwhile,
Trump is eating documents, according
to Omarosa Manigault Newman.
Trump is ripping up documents which then have to
be taped back together. Trump's family is using
private email for government business. Trump takes
documents to Mar a Lago, which is subsequently
taken back by the National Archives, and Trump
is sitting there flushing the toilet to flush
documents down the toilet. So when Trump says
people are flushing toilets 10 times, 15 times,
what he means is I'm doing it. I am just
flushing wads of documents down the toilet
and I'm kneading. He's he's really exercising
the valves by flushing again and again and
again. If you wrote this into a movie, it would
be like it's too much of a caricature. No one
would possibly believe the president is literally
flushing documents down the White House toilet,
clogging it and then having to get staff to
unclog the toilet. From the documents, it's
unbelievable now on the serious piece of this. At
what point is it time? To actually look at charges
for some of this document related stuff. Sandy
Berger was a political consultant, was the U.S.
national security adviser for Bill Clinton for
a roughly four year period. OK. He removed four
documents, four documents. And Sandy Berger was
fined $50000. Sentenced to two years probation,
had to do 100 hours of community service and
lost his security clearance for three years.
Ultimately gave up his license to practice law.
OK for documents that Sandy Berger inappropriately
took with him. And you know, the intent may not
even have been nearly as as as pernicious as
what it seems that an insidious is what Donald
Trump is trying to do here. Trump's flushing
documents down the toilet, eating them and
ripping them up and taking them to Mar a Lago.
And it's not just Trump. There are other people
that were involved in improper handling of records
or private email. All of this different stuff.
At what point is it time to say there have to
be some consequences here? We'll have the clip
of Trump talking about flushing toilets 10 to 15
times on our Instagram if you're just listening
today. Find us on Instagram at David Pakman Show